next month marks the one-year
anniversary of nya's tragic passing and
tonight in his very first
tv interview george rivera is looking to
heal
and is feeling hopeful this as he
reveals to me
his final conversation with his dear
nyah
i'm gonna ask you a hard question you
think back to that day
we have a missing person
you talked about face timing with her
that day yeah that's
that's that was that was a hard day she
called me up when she was on the boat
and she was looking for
a place to dock so i was having her take
the camera and move it around the lake
so i could see how windy the lake was
and then the phone cut off george said
he had an awful feeling
especially after naya told him the
rented pontoon didn't have an anchor
later that day a boater found nya's then
four-year-old son josie
asleep on the boat and called 911
teams searched the area and amidst his
grief this heartbreaking moment
nya's distraught father at lake pairu
for the first time
sprinting down the dock and into the
water that moment
i needed to reconnect with the water i
needed to reconnect to where she was
and my number one goal was finding her
and i didn't know how to do it except
for
getting in the water and having a moment
after five days of searching naya's body
was discovered
josie told investigators his mom had
boosted him out of the lake
and onto the boat and then disappeared
under the water
she used her last breaths to make sure
that he was
okay what does that say to you well
sort of the same mantra she used for
life you know
keep going when things are hard you keep
pushing
right it just shows you the strength of
the person i love you
in the morning it's the afternoon
how do you talk to him about his mom
we talked to him just like he's a
five-year-old
going on sex it's no different but when
he wants to talk about his mother we
talk about his mother
nyah's ex ryan dorsey has been raising
josie with help from nya's younger
sister nikaila
mikayla and ryan are doing a really
great job there were rumors that ryan
and michaela were living together
but george says that's not true how's
ryan doing
ryan's good he's a great father
i couldn't thank ryan enough for the
father that he's become
as for george's grieving process i
couldn't look at any pictures
for naya for nine months i just recently
going through this process we're going
through now
talking about her a little bit is the
only time that i've been able
to look at some pictures he shared some
of those favorite memories with us
nya in the pool on a segway celebrating
a birthday with josie
do you see her in him oh yeah he's a
healthy happy rambunctious young man he
has that spirit of joy
how will you deal with father's day i
think this father's day is going to be
really special because we're going
through this process
this is allowing me to grieve
in terms of vocalizing our relationship
together
george also wrote nia letter he composed
it here
on a stretch of california beach they
both loved
if i die young bury me and satin
lame keep sleeping soundly my angel and
we'll take it from here
i love you and miss you but i know you
know that
love dad send me away with the words of
a love
song if i went to bed every night
thinking about what she must have gone
through grieving process is tough
i gotta tell you i see that there's joy
back in you do you feel it back
i do sleeping much better and coming to
a realization
of the breadth of her life rather than
the end of her life
i feel i can move on
i have so much respect for george and he
and i had such big plans and he said
naya's probably looking down at him
right now saying
shut up dad stop talking but this is his
way of coping
and i'm sure she understands that was an
incredible conversation it really was
man what a great match